si on côté ruche donc on retrouve en
direct de moscou notre correspondant
jean didier rejoint bonjour jean didier
je le disais donc le régulateur russe
veut effacer d'une certaine manière les
terme d'invasion notamment des médias
est ce que c'est la preuve que la russie
veut garder le contrôle de l'information
oui effectivement c'est bien la preuve
que la russie a besoin enfin réédité au
minimum que sont le bien public se
retourne contre elle et donc sont
le régulateur des communications a
annoncé aujourd'hui dans ces
avertissements à plusieurs médias dont
des médias réputés comme novaïa gazeta
dont le rédacteur en chef a reçu le prix
nobel de la paix 2021 ou radio et
comment sauver qui est une des dernières
radios plus ou moins encore un peu libre
en russie et bien ils leur il les a
sommés de retirer dans leurs
publications sur leur plateforme
internet les terme d'invasion que la
guerre pour se coller aux nazis savoir
que pour des le président russe tanière
poutine il ne s'agit pas d'une guerre
mais d'une opération spéciale que les
forces russes mènent actuellement on rit
en ukraine ça tombe bien dire que le
pouvoir veut absolument contrôler à la
fois le narratif les termes utilisés
pour décrire ce qui est en train de se
passer en ukraine de façon à occuper que
l'opinion publique se retourne où
commence à devenir aux contestataires
par rapport aux objectifs de cette
opération j'en dis donc dans le même
temps il y a également eu samedi ses
déclarations de l'ex président russe
dmitri medvedev pour lui je le cite il
est temps de rompre les liens
diplomatiques avec l'ouest il a aussi
ajouté que moscou pourrait rétablir la
peine de mort des déclarations
offensives comment comment les
interpréter selon vous alors c'est ça
qui est paradoxal on connaissait le
président dimitri medvedev qui était un
homme libéral ouvert sur l'occident
beaucoup de chefs d'état occidentaux
pensaient que c'était lui qui incarnait
le nouveau visage de la russie un visage
plus ouverts par rapport à bannir
poutine et puis on voit aujourd'hui
effectivement qui qui s'est exprimé il
est aujourd'hui vice-président du
conseil de défense de la russie et il
s'est exprimé à propos notamment
d'exclusion de la russie du conseil de
l'europe en disant que ça pourrait
permettre ce serait une opportunité pour
la russie deux rétablir certaines
certains principes importants comme
notamment le retour de la peine de mort
pour punir les crimes particulièrement
graves et dans ces conditions on
s'explique mal ce retournement de
quelqu'un quand on sait de plus de 12
vers par rapport aux arcanes aux anciens
soviétique qui sont aujourd'hui à la
tête de la russie est la question que
tout le monde se pose c'est dans quelle
mesure est ce que dimitri medvedev est
libre de ses paroles encore ou s'il
n'est pas obligé de se
caler sur le narratif
du kremlin dans une logique d'opposition
avec l'occident
dernière option en fait peut-être aussi
n'est-ce qu'une bravade parce que il
estime que la russie est maltraitée par
ses partenaires occidentaux qu'il l'a
senti sommes trop durement par rapport
bien sûr au but de guerre aux invasions
à la position russe sur ce qui se passe
dans de basses et en ukraine dernière
question avec vous d'un mot également
jean d'idir voit un mot delà de la
réaction de la population russe on a vu
ces dernières heures ces derniers jours
quelques manifestations assez
sporadiques mais quand même peut-être
exceptionnelle en russie de d'opposants
au conflit à la guerre comment comment
l'opinion russe réagit-elle à cette
invasion de l'ukraine bien sûr il faut
savoir que toute manifestation contre la
guerre est interdite ce qui donne le
cadre de la liberté d'expression
dimensions variables en russie
comment la pollution comment la
population se positionne-t-elle elle est
inquiète elle ne s'attendait pas à une
opération d'une aussi grande ampleur on
s'attendait plutôt à une opération
ciblée aux pour le soutien des
populations russophones du dans de
basses et aux alentours du camp de base
évidemment aujourd'hui la donne est
complètement différente les gens sont un
peu sous le choc ils commencent à
s'organiser essayer de de faire
monter une voix contestataires il ya
notamment une centaine de personnalités
du monde du spectacle des arts et de la
culture qui a signé une lettre ouverte
comme quoi ils s'opposent à la guerre il
ya une centaine de conseillers
municipaux de villes comme moscou saint
pétersbourg mais aussi samara ou veliki
novgorod qui sont beaucoup moins connus
qui ont eux aussi su signer une tribune
d'opposition à la guerre déclarée par
enclenchée par vladimir poutine contre
l'ukraine et pour retrouver la
verticalité du pouvoir en russie on ne
peut que souligner le courage de ses
conseillers municipaux qui se sont
élevés contre contre la ligne décrétée
par le kremlin merci beaucoup
jean-didier rejoint correspondant donc
france 24 à moscou pour toutes